foreign
YouTube channel in this session we will
create a video player using python but
before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel
like the tutorial and hit the Bell icon
to never miss an update
and before we start I hope the screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section before starting let us have a
simple question to brush up on our
knowledge
and your question is which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file and your options are
the first option is dot python
the second is dot py third is dot PL and
the fourth one is dot PJ
please answer in the comment section
below and we'll update the correct
answer in the print command you can
pause the video give it a thought and
answer in the comment section
and insightful for you guys if you have
focused on building strong fundamental
skills for career growth in that case
you can check out a free course to Learn
Python Basics with a completion
certificate from scale up by simplylock
you can check the python Basics free
scale up course with that link in the
description box below
and now moving on we'll start with a
project that is creating a video player
using python
so for that
first we will create a folder
and name it as
create
to video player
using python
and
inside will open the command prompt
and type the command code space period
and press enter it will open our Visual
Studio code as I would be coding in the
visual studio code only you can code in
any ideally
that you are suitable with
so moving on first I will create a file
with the name video
now to start with our project first we
need to install the python modules we
don't have to write new code for
everything
we can use existing code written by
experts that are in the form of modules
so first we will install the modules
and the modules we would require here
would be the first one would be tick
enter and the counter is a python module
that is used to develop GUI that is
graphical user interface and there's no
need to install any module for that
as the tkinter module is a part of the
standard python Library so it's already
installed if you have installed the
python
so you don't have to install the taken
to
we will also use date time module here
so for that we'll write the command okay
space install
date
time and press enter
as you can see that it states that the
requirement is already satisfied I've
already installed the date time module
so I don't have to install that you can
just write the command pip space
installed space date time and you can
easily install the date time module
and moving on we will also install
another module that would be TK video
player for that we will write the
command pip space
installed
PK
video player
and press enter
you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied as I have already
installed the module so I don't have to
install it again
you can just write the command or you
can search
in the browser right take a video player
installation it will be directed to the
TK video player official page there you
will find the command to install the
module
so moving on
we will start
building our video player
so for that first we'll import the
packages
so first we'll import
all the classes from taken to
next
we will import
date time
to imported the date time module
now we will import
take into s t k
we have made an allies for this so we
will use TK only
so now we will import the field dialog
box so that we can open the files that
we want to browse and play on our video
player
so for that we will import
from take into
import
ant
look
now we will import take a video player
that would be taken to video class from
take a video player module so for that
we'll write from
take into video
foreign
[Music]
so for that we'll write a command
that would be the root
equal to
the Allies name that was TK
Dot
TK
so this is the simple command
that would create a root window and it
would display it on the screen
so for that we'll write root Dot
main Loop
we will save this program
and run it
you could say that that take enter
window has appeared on the screen so
this is a taken top window
so in this window only we'll create a
video player
so we'll start with that process
now uh as you've seen the taken down
window
I will show you again
so we will give it a title as we have
written TK here it's default that TK
would be here as we have made the last
name as TK only
so we will change it and we will write
as simply video play
so of course that we'll write the
command route to title and inside
we will write what we want to name the
taken to window
we'll name it as simply
video
so tinginter provides many methods and
one of them is geometry
this method would be used to set the
dimensions of the taken term window as
you have seen it has appeared in the
small manner so we will set its
dimensions
and it would also use to set the
position of the main window of the
user's desktop so for that we'll write
the command
root dot geometry
and inside we will set the x-axis as
800.
x and y axis
with pixel 700
and
from above it would be 290 that would be
the x axis it would be 290 pixels down
I'll show you like what it would be
and y axis it would be
10 so we would save this
and then the program so you can see that
we have set the x-axis is 800 y-axis as
700 and 290 pixels that was x axis we
have shifted it from 0
to here that is 290 and 10 from above
that is on the y-axis
and we can see that it has changed the
name that is it's now simply video
player
so we have changed the title of our
ticket window
so moving on
now we'll create a frame
so for that
we will write the command frame equal to
TK that was the Allies for the decanter
Dot
claim
and inside we will pass root
and we will just
pack it
so fourth frame if you don't know I will
just tell you about the frame now frame
is a rectangular region on the screen
and it can also be used as a foundation
class to implement complex widgets it is
used to organize a group of widgets so
if you want to organize any button or
any image so you can just create a frame
and organize those widgets into the
frame
and we have used the pack here so the
pack geometry manager packs widgets
related to the earlier widget tick enter
literally packs all the widgets one
after the other in the window
we can use options like fill expand and
cite to control this geometry manager
that is back
so we will
be seeing that back and we'll use it
many times so you will see the
functioning of that also
so now
we'll save it and run it
so now we will place an icon here for
simply video player we want to place
an icon so for that
we have created an icon
you can create your own
I have stored it in this logo PNG and
these images
we would be using
in a project only
that would be for the for the
forwarding and backwarding of the video
so it based all these pictures here
and now
we will place the logo.png
logo PNG file
that is we have created the icon for our
simply video player so we'll place this
on the top and for that we'll write the
command
so for that we will write
image underscore icon
we will create a variable
and that would be equal to we'll create
a photo image object
I will tell you about it
and here we will write the location
of the file we want to place it as the
icon photo
foreign
so this is the function here icon photo
and in this
we will pass Folds
comma image icon
that is in which we have stored our logo
and now we'll save this
and
run it
so first we have to close up previous
tick into window
so I will close it and
it will run a program
and you can see that we have placed the
logo for simply video player
so
I will tell you about the photo image
object first
and we have used the icon photo
method
that is used to set the title bar icon
of any tick enter window
but to set any images the icon of Title
One image should be the object of photo
image object we have created the photo
image object so what this photo image
object is about
so when we just use the photo image and
pass the file location in that it would
create a photo image object
so you can use it in any widget after
you create the photo image object
and you can pass it as any argument as
image argument in any widget
and the image object is written by the
photo image function it's easy to
display a picture in Python however the
photo image class only supports the GIF
and PPM formats which is a concern
and JPEG and jpg and PNG are the formats
that are most open used
and we are using the PNG so there's no
any problem to use that
so moving on
we will create a frame in a tick enter
window
oh that will write the command
lower underscore frame
and that would be equal to TK that was
the last name we are using for tick into
for period frame
and inside here we will pass root
and we'll set the background color
as white
and we'll write the hexa code for the
color white here and that is
6 times f
and
now we will use the back function here
we will paste this Frame
on that you will
use the variable we have created
and the pack widget
okay uh we have to place it in the
periods and it was showing error
else it would be treated as a comment
only as we have used the hashtag and we
didn't place it in inverted compass
so now we will pack it and inside we'll
use the properties as fill equal to both
so it would be fitted in the whole
window
and we will
place this at the bottom of the taken
down window
so for that we'll write send equal to
bottom and moving on
now we will create the patterns and
before creating the buttons first we
should see the demonstration of what we
are going to make
so for that I will take you to a code
that stress we will
run a program and you can see this is
the ticket window and this is the simply
video player we have paste icon there
and we have to add other functions that
would be the browse
and then we will place other button that
would be play pose
forward backward and the slider
so that you can reach to any duration
you want to see on the video you would
be paying so we'll close it
as we have
click on the play post button it has
yeah it has given an error
so we will run it again
so when we click on browse it would
direct us to any path you want
to play one of our own videos that would
be MP3 player using python
and then we'll click on play you can see
that our video is playing
so this is the demonstration of what we
are going to make
no
we will start with placing our buttons
and after that we will add the
functioning to them
so
we will create the browse button first
for that we will
create a variable load button that would
be equal to
okay
load button
inside as the root
and we'll set the text
equal to browse
and set the background color
button and that would be white only one
two three four five six
hexagon for white
and we will also set the font
for the browse button
and we have to place this hexa code in
inverted commas
else it would be termed as the comment
only
it will be starting with a cache so we
have to place it in inverted commas and
now we will set the font
for
browse button and that would be we'll
set it as calibri
and we'll also set the font size
so first we'll set it as Calgary
and set the font size as 12.
and we will also make it bold
which we have to place it
round brackets
yeah
and now we will
make a command for this button so what
does this function
what functioning will this will this
button do
so for that we'll
write command equal to and we will
name our function as plot video only
we will create this function
and and the functioning to browse the
MP4 files
now
we'll back this button
put that to write the command
tag
and inside we will use
padding
in X direction that would be 12.
and padding
by direction we will set it as four
and anchor anchor is where you want to
place the button
so I will place it in the North West
that is in the
upper left Direction
so for that we'll write the command TK
Dot and W Northwest
anchor is the positioning of the button
angle equal to TK Dot
Northwest sorry
so we have added the
padding X and Y
moving on we will
create the
tick enter video
download the window in which our video
would be playing for that
first we'll create a variable
video underscore player
and that would be equal to
T into video it would be using that
function
and inside we will pass root
scaled equal to
so you can visit that take into a video
official page and you can see these
functions there
you would easily understand like why
they are working and what's the
functioning
and now we'll pack this window
suppose that we will use the variable
and pack it
we will expand the window
and ask it
to fill in both the directions
I will show you all the functioning as
we will create all the buttons
then we will create the functions for
them
so what command we would be placing in
these buttons after that
you would be able to see
heading into window
so now we will do be making the backward
button
so for that
do a greater variable
and name it as button backward
and here we will use a photo
make a picture
in this picture
you could
see that
clearly
the folder we have placed so this is the
backward image we will use this on the
button
so for that we will create the photo
image object
inside the photo image object we will
place the location of the file
as it's already located in the same
folder so we'll just write the name of
the file that is backward.png
okay
and
actually it's showing in a we have to
place it in inverted commas
now
we will create another variable
aiming as back and inside
we will create the button
TK Dot
button
and inside
will pass lower frame as you will place
all these buttons on the lower frame we
have created
so lower frame
comma and here we will pass the image
and in image will pass the variable in
which we have created the photo image
object and so the name of the variable
is button backward
and now we will set this border
at 0 and height
equal to 50 and width also equal to 50.
and now we'll
ask this to ask this to function and for
that we'll use the
command and inside
will use Lambda
and we'll create a function with the
name skip
and we'll skip five seconds
stop back widget to pack this button
we will place it in this side
that would be left
so we'll be defining the function skip
in the meantime
um
before
make another button that would be the
forward button
and the play pose Button as we have seen
in the demonstration so first we'll
create the play post button
put that we will
create a variable
and inside will pass North frame
and here we will name
text that would be displaying code
button
it would be blame and we have to place
it in inverted commas
and we'll set the width for this button
that would be 14.
and we'll also set its height
that would be equal to 2
Library sufficient
and now
we will
add the functioning to it we will
declare
play post button very limited play pause
play functioning play and pause
now we will pack this button
so that will use the variable name
that is play post button
foreign
and inside
we will expand this button as you've
seen in the demonstration to expand it
we will use
expand equal to true
[Music]
equal to both sides
okay and we'll place it
and site
so
and side equal to left
now we will create the
forward button so for that we will
create a variable
as button forward
and inside we will create the photo
image object
and inside will pass the file location
as we have already located the file in
the same folder so we'll just name it
will write the name of the file that is
forward dot PNG
you can see in the folder that it's
forward
we'll use this image
now we have created the photo image
object and now
we build create the button for that we
will
write the command
create variable and name it is play
button
create a button with at the command TK
dot button and inside
this would be placed on the North frame
only
and
image
port
and the variable
button
forward
so now we would set its border equal to
zero
eight equal to 50
and with
equal to 50.
and we'll also Define its command
that would be equal to we'll use Lambda
and inside here we will
be forwarding the video for five seconds
it would be Lambda
and now we'll name the function as skip
we'll create a single function and it
will pass plus 5 it would be forwarding
the video with 5 Seconds
and we pass minus 5 it would be
backwarding the video with five seconds
now we will use the pack widget
to place this button
and declare
side is left
okay
so now we have created the buttons
now moving on
we will Define some functions now
and we will start with
so these are the buttons
now I'll Define some functions
so we will start with the duration
to update the duration both that will
name the function s
update underscore duration
and inside will pass the event
an event that we would be clicking
on the slide bar
so for that
first we will create a variable duration
and inside
we would be using the video info
entered
inside the square brackets
we will pass the duration
now the end time
we will create a variable
actually
with the name end time
and
pass
text in that
and that would be equal to
string
we'll use the date time module here
and time Delta
and inside
seconds would be equal to duration
so time Delta it's a duration of time
that is used for manipulating time only
so
and now
we will
create on the slider
for that
we will create a variable
progress underscore slider
and inside
Times Square brackets
pass the duration that is
to which time
we would be directing it to
and
after that we will create another
function
and name it as update scale
that would be the scale of the
slide bar
so we'll name the function as update
underscore scale and we'll pass the
event in that
and
now
we will use progress underscore value
variable and
create it
and pass the variable
ID and scripture
that we have created for video player
that would be the current mutation
foreign
duration
we will be updating the scale with the
current duration
for that we have used the current
duration method and
we will find another function
that would be the load video
and we have base a command also for the
load video
so this function would be adding the
functionality to the browse button
put that
we will create a variable and named as
file path and use the file dialog class
and
this function ask open file name
and inside if
this code
but
and if a video player
it's loading the file path
so to progress slider
foreign
speaker
to zero duration
and the form duration would also be
equal to zero
we will declare the progress later
so do not worry
and now
and the functioning
I know
some functionality
chances only so we will set the button
as play as you have seen that our button
would be displaying two options that
would be play in the pose and if we open
the file
so it would set the slider to zero only
and the button to the plane for that we
will write
play underscore pause underscore button
that is the variable of the play post
button
and inside would pass the text
in the square brackets
that would be play
when we would be choosing any mp4 file
so we would be setting the button as
play
progress underscore
value
note set
password
now we'll create another function
and name it as seek
and inside would pass the value
and we need to
this function would be using
to seek a specific time frame
for that
will
use the function seek
and pass the integer value in that
and
now we will declare the skip function
that will be adding the command to both
our buttons that would be the forward
button and the backboard button and
inside will pass
value in the form of integer
so this would be used to skip the
setting a second sorry
so here
we would be calling our seek function
and inside
will pass integer
and
progress
slide
one duration we want
to put get function
the value
you want to make it forward so we'll
just declare the progress slider
variable so don't worry we'll sort it
out
you could see that we have used the seek
function here and we'll also use the
set function
I will use some set function that is
already defined we don't have to create
and so
for that I will write the command
progress underscore value
dot set
and inside we will pass
progress
underscore slider
and use the get function
foreign
we will
declare the
play pose function
so it would be used to play and pause
the video
so we'll use Intel statement here if
foreign
defining this function first we will
create the variable that is
video player
and here we will use the tick enter
window module
side will pass root
and scaled equal to true
and now we will use the variable
and pack it
band this
equal to true
both sides
and T would be kept equal to
so before creating this function first
we'll create the variables so that we
don't get confused so we'll start with
start time start underscore
paint and that would be equal to
TK
we'll create a label
and inside you will pass root
and text equal to
string inside would pass
date time
do it
time Delta
and it's set
seconds
equal to zero
and now we will use the pack widget for
this
so start another school time
do it back
and we will
create its side
as left
and now we will create
another variable that is progress
transfer value
that is equal to TK
Dot
where and we'll pass root into it
and now we will create the variable to
press slider
foreign
[Music]
that would be the progress value as it
keeps on changing
and we will start this scale from
0
and
2
0 so in starting it would be in the
initial Point only both the from n0
scale
from N2 equal to 0 okay now we will set
its orientation
foreign
and we will set its command
equal to seek
we have defined the C function
so now
this would be easy for you guys to
understand it
now we'll pack this progress slider
and set its side equal to
left
and it should
fill the x that it's width
so for that we'll write fill equal to
X
and expand
equal to true
so we have created the variable start
time progress value progress slider
so we are left with end time
and
this will create a label
pass root into that
text
equal to
convert it into string
that would be date time
Dot
time Delta
and inside will pass
seconds
that would be equal to zero
and now we'll use the back configure
a configure widget
to packet
so
back
and
side equal to
left
so set
foreign
function
and inside
will pass duration
okay we have defined it here
sorry
to create this we need
the video player
variable
now
we will
update the duration here
so first update duration
and if
we need to go clear
Dot bind
and if it's second changed
so we'll update the scale here
and if video player
dot point
ended
so what will pass the video ended
function
don't create in the video ended function
so we'll create that
update the update duration update scale
let me do end it
so we are left with Video Edit function
and the Playboys function
so we will complete that first so if
video player
is post
of course so set
video player
to play when you click on the player
post button
and now we'll set its text
to underscore
pose
underscore
button and inside the square
brackets
will pass the
text
and that would be equal to
if the video player is paused
so we'll play it and set the button text
as pause
and
else
[Music]
video player
foreign
function there
and set the text
and a score
button
for the text will use the square
brackets
we'll set it as a
so we are done with the play pose
function now we are left with
the video ended function
so
that
[Music]
create the function and pass the event
through it
so it would handle the video when the
video would be ended
okay so we have to
just above
okay we will arrange them
first we will complete a
function
so
put that
use to press slider
and set it as
progress underscore slide
right now
and pass the two
the duration at which it would be in it
and set the play post button text
pass this in
square brackets
as clear
as the video would be completed so we
would
turn this back into the plane
and we will set the progress
slider
set
at zero
so now let's see what else you're
getting
so very Zone with errors
foreign
and click on play button
so we have got some error
in line 66 and equal to
okay
[Music]
okay I'll browse but I'm not showing
so let's save this and run again
actually close to previous window and
run it again
okay so we are getting a browse button
downwards
okay
based on video player between as
these are
in the packings only so first we will
place our browse button then the video
player then the backboard button then
the pause button
and then the forward button
and we have named it as play
let's save this
and run it
join close the keyway stick enter window
now you can see that the browse button
has
automated's position so we'll click on
the browse button
let's open in the downloads and this MP3
player using python only
click on the play button
the file spring click on the pause
button
and you can
see the functioning of forwarded
backward
buttons
so
we are done with the project if you have
any doubt you could just ping in the
comment section and with that we have
come to the end of this session
and I have something for you guys
just wait
so if you are aiming to get certified in
Python Programming course
and you want to build up python software
development career in that case you can
check this python certificate course by
simply enough which will open the doors
for the best career options and
opportunities to find the details of
this python certification course you can
check in the link in the description box
below
it would be the ideal solution to help
you build your career in the right
direction and I hope this session was
interesting and informative if you liked
it please let us know in the comment
section below and also do subscribe to
our Channel and stay tuned for More
Foods
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here